The sun had long since fallen out of the
sky by the time Josh finished giving
Kyle the scoop on Fractal's Define Nano
S. Kyle gave his familiar nod of
approval as he admired his friend's
work, fighting the urge to flail his
arms like a marionette on speed, which
had long been his trademark.
Actually, he kind of nailed you there.
You know what? Whatever. Where do the
drives go in this thing?
They're back here.
Flushed with emotion, they stared
longingly into each other's eyes. the
the emotion
longingly. There was no longingly.
Okay, let's let's just try to
Yeah, right. I mean, okay, so what else
can we stuff in this thing?
No.
Kyle's Freudian slip betrayed his true
emotions, his heart taking over for his
mind. Choose your own adventure with the
defined Nano S from Fractal Design. The
case offers custom water cooling
options, full-size hardware support, and
top class cable management in a compact
design. Click the link in the
description for more info.
What's up, guys? If you're watching this
video on the day of upload, the GTX 1060
from Nvidia has just hit the market at a
starting MSRP of $2.49 with a $50
premium for the Founders Edition.
Unfortunately, these prices were
announced this month in an online
statement, so we couldn't really gauge
Jensen's body language on stage.
Assuming Nvidia has stayed true to their
word on pricing, however, the GTX 960
successor puts itself in direct
competition with AMD's new RX 480, which
starts at $240 for the 8 gig reference
card and around $30 to $50 more for the
custom board variants when they arrive.
Essentially, both GPU manufacturers are
competing for the hearts of mainstream
gamers, and they're both thirstier than
a girl gamers Twitch chat. So today
we'll see how these cards stack up in
terms of performance and value after we
take a quick look at the green team's
new card. The Pascalbased GTX 1060
sports the GP 106 GPU with 10 streaming
multipprocessors and 1280 CUDA cores, a
base and boost clock of 156 and 178 MHz
respectively, a memory clock of 406 MHz
with 6 gigs of GDDR5 on a 192-bit bus
and a TDP of 120 watts. The cooler
features a new but familiar polygonal
design with a blower style fan that
moves hot air out the back of the
chassis and an aluminum heat sink that
provides 50% more coverage than the GTX
960, which offers 25% more coverage than
Obamacare. At the end of the 10-in
shroud is a single six pin power plug
that's placed well past where the short
PCB ends, indicating some fancy
soldering work. Another interesting move
here is the omission of an SLI finger
and SLI support for this card
altogether. Somehow, I know Jay's still
going to find a way to water cool four
of these things. But apart from that, I
agree with Nvidia that multi-GPU setups
should usually be reserved for only the
highestend cards when there's no faster
single card option available. At the
back of the card, you'll find the
standard assortment of reference display
outputs for Pascal, free display port
1.4, one HDMI 2.0b, and a dual link DVI.
I'm happy to report that overclocking
the GTX 1060 and MSI Afterburner was an
absolute delight. Enthusiasts will
rejoice that the chip has more headroom
than a ho riding shotgun, which allowed
me to dial in a 230 MHz offset without
touching the voltage, bumping the max
core clock to over 2.1 GHz. Throughout
my testing, the card never rose above
82° C on my test bed using a 5820K at
4400 MHz, a Gigabyte X99 Gaming G1
Wi-Fi, and 16 gigs of DDR4 at 2666 on
Windows 10. And in case you're curious,
here's how the card sounds.
The 1060 was using the 368.64 press
driver to run all games at 1920 x 1080
and 2560x440.
I was about to run 4K benchmarks on this
card, but that was before 10our Nancad
guy told me it'd be a waste of time.
Here's a look at all the cards tested
today, which either come factory
overclocked or have been tweaked
manually by yours truly. On a side note,
I've dialed back the MSI GTX 1070's
aggressive OC mode to the gaming profile
that end users can expect out of the
box. With that said, let's get on to why
you're really watching this video. In
Fire Strike Extreme, the GTX 1060 nets
an overall score 3.5% higher and a
graphics score 5.2% higher than the RX
480. A rather small victory. Also,
notice how far we've come since the GTX
960 with a 71% increase after one
generation. Nice gains, Nvidia. Most
companies like Apple would have just
made the card thinner. GTA 5 gives us a
first glimpse of real world gaming
performance with the GTX 1060 yielding
14% more frames than the RX 480 at full
HD and a 26% increase at 1440. The 1060
also barely manages to best the 970 at
both resolutions. Clearly, the GTX 1070
and 960 are in leagues of their own at
opposite ends of the spectrum. Hitman
2016 is the only title where we saw the
RX 480 lead across the board, though by
a smaller margin of 4 to 5%. Here, the
970 takes a big back seat, and the GTX
960 is basically riding in the trunk. In
Metro Last Light, the tides shift again
in Nvidia's favor. At full HD, the GTX
1060 saw 14% more frames than the RX 480
and 21% higher frame rates at quad HD.
Finally, in Crisis 3, there's a pretty
close standoff between our three
mid-range cards, but the 1060 barely
takes the crown at both resolutions.
From our testing, it definitely seems
that the 1060 outperforms the RX 480 by
a wider margin at quad HD than it does
at 1080. This time, beating out Team Red
by 20%. When totaling the average frame
rates, we find the GTX 1060 to be 25%
slower than its GP 104 Broki, 8.5%
faster than the GTX 970, 9.5% faster
than the RX 480, and it outright poops
on the chest of our GTX 960. Now,
clearly compared to the RX 480, the 1060
is the faster chip overall. But can it
dethrone the Polaris card as the current
value king? For our frames per dollar
test, I used the current lowest pricing
that I could find between Amazon and
Newegg for all of our cards with the
exception of the 1060, which we're
basing off of the official MSRP. As we
can see here, the RX480 remains the best
bang for the buck option with 1.9 frames
per dollar compared to 1.7 FPD with the
GTX 1060. If Nvidia hopes to pluck this
title from AMD's hand, we'll have to see
a custom GTX 1060 that's just as fast
retail for no more than $262
to achieve an FPD higher than the RX
480. Should this be the case, I
sincerely hope it doesn't push the 480
over the edge. Every card has its limit,
after all. So, in the end, which card is
right for you? Well, if you want to make
the most informed decision, I would wait
to see what the custom board pricing
looks like from both GPUs once they hit
the shelves. But from what we know now,
the GTX 1060 is a very fast card for the
price and often scores notably higher
frame rates than the RX 480, especially
at quad HD. As I mentioned earlier,
while I didn't have time to test it,
this also leads me to believe that the
1060 would have a bit more longevity
when it comes to VR. If you got that
baby daddy money, the GTX 1060 gets my
full recommendation. That being said, I
wouldn't call the 1060 an RX 480 killer.
AMD's new card is still a compelling
choice for 1080 gaming and entry-level
VR whose value may still have some
greater appeal for those on slimmer
budgets. But that's going to do it for
now, guys. So, let me know what you
think of this card in the comments. And
don't forget to toss me a like on this
video if you enjoyed it. Before you go,
check the description for the bestest
t-shirts in all the webs and notice my
Amazon affiliate link down there. All
I'm saying is notice it. As always, I'm
Kyle with awesome sauce network for now.
Thank you guys for watching. Subscribe
to the channel if you haven't already,
and I will see yall in the next video.